welcome to this video playing master
Zachary from the US maybe something else
play a French defence ok the we never
not well and then this kind of stuff
it's not a bad line for white not at all
it sound very exciting to play sort of
exchange French check oh it's allowing
me to trade the bishop right away that's
not happening very often so I managed to
trade off the light squared Bishop that
that's always good news really and I
have some ideas now in this position
trying to maybe get to a position where
a night is better than his bishop maybe
you should play see form sooner than
later ok glad to take some control over
you five and no Knight a5 controlling
see form yeah white must be very careful
here if he is not can easily drift into
a bad position ok interesting wants to
probably push it all the way
okay my f6 is seams seams seams all
right I want to prevent the night coming
to e5 so after age 597 I need to have
six pawn to have this is protected now
my dream scenario loopy just trade all
the heavy pieces and then I'm winning
this end game rather comfortably because
of his very bad porn structure okay
interesting move c4l still wants to play
that may be queen here covering the pawn
covering on the the square I know it now
I hung hung see 70 hmm they are not
ideal the Queen f7 I played played too
quickly superficial moves
okay this looks a bit funky wit still if
I can get get it back into play it does
not really matter that much definitely a
bad play by me allowing that not sure
what you should do really
now it's got some active pieces but that
you fall right on age 80 ah I really
want to get this back into the game
like it's a queen f5 it's not so easy to
play for black I don't have much space
maybe I'll just take it to play will
create after that but yeah probably I
need to trade pieces to reduce the
immediate pressure and if he takes now I
get a square for the night ok ok from
this should I should probably really
take i won them
how to play Queen ji-sun I need I need
two nite f7 I cannot play without this
piece he might play see for now maybe
but I don't care I must I must activate
him we go c4d takes Knight checks I
think I have queen bee five winning
winning the piece at least this is what
I relied upon okay so Queen B 5 let's
check this or is there a checkmating IDM
I am almost checkmate Queen B 5 Queen f3
a move like that
just got this chicken unbelievable stuff
amazing yeah Queen B 5 has got Queen f3
exactly queen of three I really relied
on this move that's that's really a big
problem
strange stuff okay couldn't take off
because of Queenie age
time morning
i think i'm just getting the porn all
right
hi Scott Bishop be a gem this should be
winning really i win the bishop if it
takes nice tub and move wipe that I
should move the king bag should have
just played a 6b five anyway check check
check no case losing all the pipes no
resins yeah that was a weird game with
the with me putting the night on a jade
this is a case where I think some
precise moves him would have probably
gone me a very nice position so here c6
maybe c6 Queen f7 is definitely wrong I
mean this is wrong problem was I didn't
really recognize that I'm wondering this
it's not it's not fatal if I give up the
poor maybe I should have done that
actually just play this position upon
down but okay yeah maybe I should have
taken h5 here actually okay the very
curious situation here whence we was
with the c forum here with this business
when I was relying upon that this is not
working and here Queen B 5 is answered
by queen aquata 60 stronger you Wow 26
uh-huh or that sets a terribly strong
move that sets a Quincy 8 coming up and
there's also Queen f7 friend I cannot
even play a move like that I just jam
eight but I mean any movie I cannot
spread any Queen f7 also this is the
best line and it's really not good for
me check I not here of course to check
to him and this is this is looking
terrible just lost so this is what I was
hoping for I mean quimby files what I
was banking on it is with wasn't working
and she it's about now white slightly
better maybe but this is Sir this is a
mistake it gives up the porn I had
expected this move trying to do a
counter-attack this I can yeah i can
even I have the time to play a success
this is a goner anyway yeah i blundered
with this Queenie 6 move after if he
doesn't do that it's still interesting
yeah here this this should be winning
from like I didn't play it well it it
should should win who tough game thanks
for watching